welcome to this session on image
understanding using deep neural networks
my name is Matias additio and in this
talk we will look at the practice of
deep learning for real-world computer
vision applications so this talk will
not only demonstrate the capabilities of
the neural network functionalities that
were introduced in version 11 of the
world frame language but also the
built-in flexibility when you do
developments in the world frame language
using both deep learning functionalities
and traditional functions and algorithms
let us get started by clearing up some
preconceived notions about deep learning
in practice most probably you don't need
data set with 100 million images you
don't need to come up with a fancy
network architecture and you don't
necessarily need to be running an
expensive job on a thousand GPUs for
weeks in order to solve your problem
instead you may select an existing
network architecture and only make those
tweaks that are necessary to your
applications or you may select a network
that has already been trained and then
use it directly or find units based on
your datasets regarding data if your
data set is a little small you can
augment it by for example flipping
images left-to-right rotations and so
forth as for the training you can get
completely set up on a laptop or
workstation as long as you have a recent
NVIDIA GPU and once you are set up you
may ever complete the training on this
machine or transfer the setup to the
clouds for bigger jobs finally for the
IP our parameters for training you can
trust the world from language to choose
appropriate value automatically for you
or you may pick up such values
existing publications deep learning is a
state-of-the-art technique in many
computer vision applications from
self-driving cars to microscope image
diagnosis and so forth in this talk we
look at three applications and they will
show three different scenarios or
configuration with respect to the
magnitude of data sets or networks being
used the first example will be out of
quarry major travel and in this
application we'll use directly features
from an already trained network the
second example will be blind image
quality assessment and in that
application we will tweak an already
trained network and as well as
demonstrating data augmentation finally
our last example will be colorization of
black and white pictures and we will do
so by training an existing network
architecture with our own data right so
let's start with our first application
content-based image retrieval in this
application a user will provide an input
image and the task is to find the images
from a data set that has been previously
analyzed process etc to find the images
from these data sets that are visually
similar to the input image so let's see
what's the approach we are going to take
to solve this problem so in the approach
we are choosing we will describe an
image via features and these features
will be compared with all the features
corresponding to all the images in the
data set and whatever nearest features
are found in this data set will be the
pictures that we are looking for so in
order to compute features we are going
to use a generic framework that has
already been trained for just image
recognition and we are going to remove
the last layers of the strain network
the layers that are very specific to the
recognition task and use as features
essentially the values of the last two
last layers of this network and after
the features are extracted we will use a
generic K nearest neighbor to pick up
the best matches in our dataset so as it
turns out the functionality we need
which is to access the lead features of
general recognition network this
functionality is already available in
the warframe language so for this
application we won't have to use the
existing deep networks functions instead
we will rely on other machine learning
high level functionality let me
introduce the function that performs the
general recognition Mathematica it's
called image identify it's one of those
very large projects involving a huge
amount of training and data and that
returns values categories and
information about the image so let's see
how we are going to leverage this
network to extract features this
representation here is not exactly the
network being used by images on TV but
it illustrates the concept of what we
are doing we are essentially preserving
all the stages in the network except the
very last layers that are shown here
conceptually in red because these last
layers are just too specific to the
recognition application so we don't have
to do that surgery using deep network
functions here because this is built in
the warframe language for that Network
so I can just create a feature extractor
function for an image and if I apply
that to that image you see that you get
a result vector of values of length
thousand twenty four that are the
features that correspond to this image
it is important that we are able to also
compute these features from a file that
is told on disk and for this out of Co
version will just essentially import the
image and compute the values and as you
see after I do that I get the exact same
values out of co in Co now that we can
compute features for any image either in
in Co out of core now we need to
construct op dataset or acquire a
dataset so for the purpose of this talk
I just got the first 500 images that
were written by your search engine for
the query monuments and this is the
number my gods and let's look at some
random sample from it
these are the addresses and the
corresponding pictures for this random
four images and you see that I have not
done any curation on this data
it's just how it came and we can now
compute the features for each of the
picture in this dataset and that takes a
bit of time so I have pre computed that
already and at the end you get a results
which is just a matrix of five hundreds
elements because there are 500 pictures
in my dataset and by 1024 which
correspond to the number of features for
each image right so we have a query the
data sets and we have computed the
features that correspond to each image
of this data set so the last thing that
we need to do offline is to compute a
nearest neighbor function that will take
as input a feature and return a URL from
the data set
once this is done the retrieval in
itself or an input image is consisting
only in extracting features for this
image and returning the top
se5 URL from the datasets that are the
closest to the input image and then
importing each of this URL for example
if I look at a query an image of the Taj
Mahal and I ask for the top five picture
in my dataset you see that the top two
pictures are good hits and the second
number three and four may be reasonable
and number five is certainly off again
the data set is not curated I do not
know if the has found me two pictures of
the Taj Mahal in my data set or anymore
so that's it that example about similar
travel is now complete and we can move
on to our next example our second
example is an application for blind
image quality assessment I will explain
in a second what each of these word
means but let's look at an example of
what we want to do we are given an image
and the job is to compute our score
between 1 which correspond to a very bad
image to 100 that corresponds to an
excellent image so it is blind because
there is no reference image as
essentially no supports for our
algorithm apart from the input image and
this quality assessment or score is
actually an opinion score that
correspond to what a human observer
would rate that picture so what I'm
going to demonstrate has been outlined
in in the paper below and we are going
to use
data set called life in the wild that
you can pick up online if you wish so so
let's see how we are going to approach
this problem how are we going to do that
one thing I should mention ahead is that
our data set is rather small about a
thousand images and we've only that
amount of data you cannot really hope to
Train 6s fully a network from scratch so
instead we will rely on an existing
network that has already been trained
for generic classification tasks and we
are going to remove from this network
the last parts that are too specific to
the recognition tasks it was trained on
and replace those last parts with new
layers that are specific to our problem
and these new layers will be trained on
our own data set so in practice this is
how it's going to work we'll have
essentially twisted three stages in the
first stage we will stripe already
trained network of its last layers this
is very similar to what we have done in
the previous example then we will add
new layers and we will train them using
our net trained function and the third
stage is regression where we go from
features to an actual number and this is
a generic function in the world from
language called credit that is going to
help us do that job so let's go step by
step one two three and get going first I
introduced the datasets we are going to
use it's called life in the world it has
little more than a thousand images and
there has been about seven thousand
people who have been writing those
images
so you see on this train a sample of
eight pictures all the pictures from the
data set are pretty much coming right
away from the camera there's no further
processing on them
and you can see for each image two
numbers the first number here is the
average score which correspond to the
mean of all the scores that were given
by all the human observers we have rated
that picture and the second number is an
indication of the variation of these
ratings and this is actually the
standard deviation of all the ratings by
all the people for that picture so this
is a you know a fair picture with
standard deviation that puts it's you
know to the poor category or towards the
good category this will be an excellent
pictures with a very high score and that
will be as I guess there's a consensus
would be very bad pictures because of
camera motion so let's that's a general
presentation of the data sets because
it's small we are now going to see how
we can augment it and we will perform
data commentation by taking random crops
within each image and each of this crop
we have the same rating as was given by
the human observers so to do this craft
we are first resizing the input image
and then randomly taking a smaller
rectangle within this image so in this
little piece of code here that is the
function drop I resize the image to size
a given size and then I defined a random
starting position for my crop and
eventually I just do the actual cropping
of the size
$2.99 by $2.99 which happens to be the
size I would need later on during the
training part so I can define the
function and if I crop if I perform 10
random drops of this image you see if
you focus for example on the eyes of
these puppets you see that in the
original image on the towards the center
and not so much on the top and for
example in that crop eyes are completely
at the top etc so this detail
commentation has two benefits the first
one is that it provides more data to my
training and the second is that it can
help with some stability in the training
because we want the training the network
that as it's being trained to be robust
to this type of small changes so another
thing that we are not going to do for
this application but that you may find
in our literature is to do reflections
so the idea here will be that if that
picture is rated say very well then this
picture which is just a rotation from a
reflection from left to right will also
be equally well so that that's it from
my description of a dataset and now we
are going to move on to the steps 1 2 3
of the processing from image to quality
so now we move on to the first part of a
pipeline which is to describe an image
using features that are corresponding to
the late the late stages of an already
trained classification network that is
something that we have seen in the
previous application example using the
network corresponding to the function
image identify in the warframe language
here I'm going to use a model that has
been published
Google called inception tree and that
model has been translated into the
warframe language formats so it is
readily
importable so as you see there is a good
amount of layers and parameters to train
in this network and good luckily for us
we don't need to do that training it has
been trained already so what we are
going to do instead is just to cut the
last two layers here because they
correspond ready to the categorization
task that inception tree was trained for
and we will just want to access these
features from layer of 30 on the world
so we're just getting rid of number 31
and 32 so this type of surgery on the
network or editing is very easy with the
warframe language so before we perform
this operation you see that that picture
has been recognized as an obelisk it
doesn't matter that it's wrong or that
it will be good what really were
interested in is in this feature so I'm
just going to remove the last two layers
of the network and now you see that my
output is a vector of size 2048 which
really is the features I was looking
after and now to define my extraction
function is just a straightforward
forward pass of this network and if I
apply that to the input image you see
that I get a vector of reals describing
the image of length 2048 so we are able
now to extract features from an image
that correspond to a generic well
trained large network let's see how we
can now find you in this network
on our data set these features we have
extracted using inception tree ready for
us to be used and they will consist in
the training set for this little piece
of network that we are going to use in
stage 2 so what is going to happen when
you construct the training set for this
stage 2 network is to essentially
compute drops of each image of the data
sets extract the inception features on
them and repeat this for each image in
the data set so we have 248 features for
each crops I have computed all this
information before and stop that into a
data structure in Mathematica so you can
see here each picture is stored with a
name of the file with the quality the
mini opinion score the standard
deviation of this quality rating and
then the features that are computed for
30 crops in total I'm going to explain
in a second why we had to introduce this
additional information which is the
class but for now let's just say that
the class of the picture is just the
quantization of the mini opinion score
so the mini opinion score goes from 1 to
100 so if you are from 0 to 20 there is
one here then you are bad if you are
from if a picture is from 20 to 40 then
it's poor 40 to 60 will be fair picture
60 to 80 will be a good picture and then
excellent again we are going to see
right away why we had to do that we have
this 1,000 images with all this
information we are going to now separate
dataset into training and testing so I
keep 20% for testing I don't need to
keep any for cross for validation tests
because essentially the function we are
going to use is will do cross-validation
internally so I'm just getting random
samples to separate my dataset into test
and training and then construct my data
which is it taking as input the CNN
features from inception tree and taking
as output this class bad to good fail
etcetera right so now let's look a
little in little more details at this
little piece of network that we are
adding at the end of inception tree in
our pipeline so this is the the pub
number two in our pipeline and this is
essentially fine tuning inception tree
so that it's correspond to our
application which is to the arrival
number for quality inception tree the
late features optimized for category of
an object whereas we would like to have
a different semantics which correspond
to the quality of an image so that's the
goal does the whole of this little
network here is to somehow transfer the
semantics from features relating to
image cat to object category to features
relating to image quality and that
little network is pretty simple it's
just a couple of hidden layers and
non-linearity and essentially we are
going it takes as input the inception
tree features a friend 248 goes through
these fully connected layers with
non-linearity
and then we'll add to the category bad
to offer good and excellent and the idea
again behind this little network is that
it's going to convey the information we
need so that the final predictor has
good features to work with so I can stop
training that using the GPU on my laptop
and I just train this little net using
my training sets using using the testing
set for as validation on the GPU of my
laptop so actually this is going to take
in a couple of minutes which for the
purpose of this talk is bitten off so I
have already performed this operation
and the pre computed results of an
accuracy on the testing set of about 50%
which doesn't maybe as much as looking
at the confusion matrix again on this
little network so you see that you have
essentially you know a proper
categorization and some some miss
categorization which is just to be
expected given the strong standard
deviation of this course so in the
classic scheme now that we have trained
a network to compute features that are
relevant to the quality assessment we
are going to strip this network so that
it no longer output a category but it
just puts the the feature vector so this
would be a fine-tuned feature extractor
and if I put that into a function you
see that if I give the first training
sample I get a vector of five features
that will be the base of the predictor
engine coming right after that so in
this step this little fine tuning piece
of network as
transform the semantics of the features
from object category into quality
category and we are now ready for the
final step in our image quality
assessments pipeline with step 3 which
is the final predictor and that final
predictor just takes as input the five
features that correspond to image
quality and gives as output a number
between 1 and 100 which is the quality
so similarly to what we have done in the
stage 2 we just construct the training
and testing sets where the in the output
will be the mean opinion score equality
and the input will be this fine-tune
features for all these crops so if I
construct training and testing data set
these are three random samples from the
training set you see that they consist
of five features as input and output one
number this was very very poor image so
to perform this regression we are going
to use the function predict which is
built in the world frame language and
this function predict will automatically
pick up the best methods given my data
so according to predict the best was to
choose the linear regression and it
found very strong regularization
coefficient for this linear regression
and now I propose that we do a little
bit of science and assess the
performance of image quality technique
used on the testing data so that would
be very easy to do using ableton
function so predictor measurements it
turns out that in the field of image
quality there are other indicators that
are of statistics that are not built in
predict or measurements yet so I'm going
to compute them on the sides they are
essentially correlation quiff
and now we can see and assess results on
the testing set so you see and this plot
a few things on this axis is actually
the predicted value that our system
gives and on the vertical axis is the
actual value that people have rated the
image for so the closer you are to this
line the closer of the system is
mimicking human behavior so you see that
we have the slope that is slightly
different but the trend is rather good
with a bunch of points were essentially
along this diagonal and that was just a
tiny bit of science that I have felt we
should be doing but now let's move on to
assembling everything into the final
predictor right so now that we have
trained and created everything the last
piece is just to assemble each of the
steps and chain them together so the
function that's going to predict the
quality is pretty simple it takes as
input an image compute the inception
features then compute the fine-tune
features and finally this goes for
predictor to perform the regression so
to conclude that example on blind image
quality assessments if you give that
image of Superman house or something you
will get a result of 54 which correspond
to a fair image so that's it for our
deep learning blind image quality
assessments and now we are going to move
on to our last example and this last
example is automatic correlation of
black and white pictures so what is the
problem we are tackling you know this is
just the the classic problem of getting
as input a grayscale image
creating a color image from it and the
challenge here is really that this is
happening automatically and to end
without any user intervention so more
concretely we have to go from a
luminance image our system needs to
estimate a and B chrominance channels
that are making sense with respect to
this luminance image and afterwards they
are being combined this is of course
trivial into a leb image that can be
displayed this is a work that was
published in SIGGRAPH in 2016 and I'm
actually happy to demonstrate here the
work that was performed also by Sabrina
Jo a student at the warm summer school
in 2016 so let's see now how we are
going to tackle this problem so how are
we going to do that at all without any
user input so that will be the the
wonders and limitations of deep learning
we are going to use our own data and we
are going to train an existing network
architecture from scratch on our own
data and let the data guide the
colorization
but first let's look at how challenging
this problem is essentially it's a very
indifferent problem and the way this
system will work is that we'll try to
incorporate some prior knowledge about
what's in the image to help constrain
the colorization so let's look at this
tree picture as examples to see the
challenges we are facing if we look at
this lady here and just look at the
shirt that shirt based on fashion could
have pretty much any color so if I pick
up random colors in lav space of a given
lumen
that correspond to this shirt here all
these are acceptable colors for this
shirt so in this case it it's hard to
get any prior knowledge into the
colorization of this picture now if we
look at that second image here this
image of a road if we look at the
picture we in sense of expectations we
know that the road is likely to be some
type of shade of grey and that cause
typically most commonly white red black
etc so if I that that's something we can
visualize if I randomly sample colors
for the cows you will see that even
though they all in the proper leb range
the some of them are just completely
exceptional on the road so the
correlation we will be able to be guided
if it knows it's a car and as I keep on
introducing concepts to explain how that
is that system is it's incorporating
prior knowledge to colorize let's look
at the final picture here which is a
picture of just an outdoor scene and
here we don't really need to look at the
higher level features of that image if
we just look at the texture we know that
if a flat region of an outdoor scene is
towards the top of the image it's more
likely to be blue sky and if the texture
is in such a way towards the bottom it
might be grass from outdoor and this is
information that can be leveraged by
theorization algorithms so now that I
have introduced these concepts we are
going to see in detail how the network
is going to incorporate this prior
knowledge and how it's going to be
architects to express that
right so let's take the time to look at
an overview of the network architecture
so our goal is to go from a grayscale
image to a color image but let's see how
we get there first the image will be
sent through a network that will compute
low-level features essentially edges
corners and so forth and distro level
features will be sent to two different
networks one network is so-called global
level feature network and this will
compute global level features that will
then be sent to a classification network
and this classification network will
give a category as outputs and the
training will also try to be optimal in
terms of classification not just color
color and classification so the fact
that we want to do classification will
kind of coerce the features that our
output by this module here to be
relevant to very high level
representation and now going back to
this low level features they are also
sent to a mid level feature network and
here we expect that this network will
learn to represent features chat such as
texture etc so the output this mid level
features here that output here as well
as these global level features output
here other than fused or combined and
they form the input to the last and
final engine in your system which is the
chrominance generation network and that
will be the module in charge of creating
the en bit channels and afterwards you
can use this original luminance channel
and the computed a and B channels to
create this color image
so what I'm going to do now is to go
over each of these blocks and explain
what is going on inside each of them and
the first Network we are going to look
at is the network that computes the low
level features so as you see this
network is consisting in a pipeline of
convolutional layer followed by batch
normalization and then non-linearity
with a Rayleigh layer and to give to
give you more insight about what's going
on I'm actually going to jump ahead pick
up the result of the training and
extract the low-level network that has
been trained and show you what's
happening inside it so I'm going to just
do that essentially this train low-level
is it is exactly that Network but where
all the parameters have been trained
already and if I take as input the
luminance of this bird you see that the
output of the low-level network is 512
by 28 by 28 and that's something that
you can interpret 512 images of size 28
by 28 so if I look at ten random of such
images out of this 512 this is the type
of features that have been computed in
this low-level network so we have you
know essentially come trusts gradients
and so forth and that is for this
low-level network this low-level network
is feeding to networks the so-called
mid-level network and a global level
network alright so let's move on to the
second network we are going to describe
the so-called mid-level feature network
and that network takes as input
the low-level features and essentially
continues to apply the convolutional
layer followed by batch normalization
and hallu which is the element-wise
non-linearity and essentially it's going
to derive features that are more and
more high-level compared to the low
level once again if we apply the same
trick of picking up the result of the
training extracting the part that
correspond to this mid level Network we
can then see what's happening inside it
so the results of this network will be
256 by 28 by 28 volume dance is
interpretable as 256 images of dimension
28 by 28 and if we look at what's here
we have unnormalized features where
supposedly we have a better encoding of
higher-level properties like texture and
so forth as we continue a little to of
the networks in our system the global
level network here's a consisting of at
the early stage the classical
convolutional layer followed by batch
normalization and roller and towards the
end we have two fully connected layers
that will be important to derive
classification information these Network
takes as input the low level features
and the output is going to be sent to
the fusion module as well as to the
classification module so if we look at
how it looks like in the actual results
we give the low level features and we
get as a result 512 numbers this
numbers have a dual purpose they were
encoding classification information as
well as high-level information that is
now going to be fused with the mid-level
information so now we are reaching the
part where the global and mid-level
features are joining and this is
combined in the so called fusion Network
where essentially we are making sure
that the dimensions are matching between
these global level features and the mid
level features so the global features
are sent through a free connected layers
batch normalization raloo and then they
are being reshaped and combined with the
mid level features so this is how it
looks like in the actual network then
after training and if we look at the
result after fusion we have 256 by 28 by
28 volumes which we can visualize ten of
them randomly and these the information
that is going to be used to do the
colorization so the premise is that that
in these images here that you see it is
256 images are encoding both information
about what is in the image in terms of
high-level objects as well as what's in
the image in terms of textures and of
mid-range information so I'm not
presenting in this to the network that
does the classification because it's
very similar to things we have seen
before in the other examples so the last
network I want to show in this tool is
the network that performs the generation
of color so that network takes as input
in the fused global and mid level
features and you see that it will
perform a series of convolution batch
normalization and run
and we've rifled in between upsampling
layers were essentially the size of the
image doubles so that's that somehow how
iteratively the network is going to
learn how to colorize the image so this
is the chain final chain if we look at
how it looks like in the actual train
Network we can now see after I give the
fused features as input what's the
dimension of the output so 2 by 2 24 by
2 24 after all this up sampling and so
forth and if I now look at the channels
that correspond to this data these are
my a and B channels but the a and B
channels in the color space not supposed
to be between 0 & 1 the actual range is
between as you see here between minus 1
and 1
pretty much so I am to construct the
final color image I'm combining the
luminance then a risk at version of the
a Channel and a risk adverse of the
beach handle and this voila
this is the result of the correlation of
these birds so you will see that so it's
not perfect but it did a pretty good job
but finding color for the leaves and the
feathers and the sky even though some
parts of the sky are still gray so we
have concluded the - of all the parts of
the network but there is little more to
it than what I just presented briefly a
lot of what you see here is is
essentially plumbing to make sure that
the connection between all these
networks is appropriate but what I want
to emphasize is
so remember that this is an optimization
problem during the training phase and so
we need to have values loss functions
that to assess our progress during
training so this in network the final
network takes an image will have will be
separated into leb these will then this
is the a and B channels that will be
compared from the actual image to the
output of the colorization network so we
have 1 loss function here that says how
different the a and B channels are from
the ground truth and we have a different
value that is being optimized which is
the classification problem so the global
level features are being sent to a
classifier and this is compared to the
output to the story to the input class
for the given image so these two values
here are being optimized at once we are
going now to see how this is happening
so the previous network was that you
just saw is the one that is being sent
to in that train we will give a training
set consisting of images as power of 2
files and classes the same for the
validation set and let me say a few
words how the network am showing has
been trained we used a subset of image
identifiers data set so we train on
about 350,000 images which is about 5%
of the actual data set and we trained
for 5 epochs that means we went 5 times
through the entire images and that took
about 14 hours on machine with a single
Titan GPU so essentially I'm showing
results on a checkpoint of the training
not very very close from the beginning
but definitely not close from
convergence either and this is
we have already seen a few results but
now let's put it all together we will
import train Network and that train
network is still doing classification
and then things that we are not
interested in anymore
what we want really is to go from the
image and compute the features colorize
and that's it so we are just going to
you know excise this train network and
take what we need make sure that it
accept images as input so that we don't
need to worry about doing this type of
conversion ourselves and finally our
colorized function is as such we extract
the luminance channel this is being sent
to the correlation network then each of
the channels a and B are we scaled
according to the actual range values and
finally we are resized to the actual
dimensions of the image and convert to
you know la b and then risk RGB image
altogether so if we do that on this bird
from end to end this is the correlation
result that we have seen before so
that's it for this application about
colorization and as this talk is
finishes i would like to thank you and
will part on more result of this
Croatian Network